so
so
um
this is an example of why guys say you
can't take a hoe into a housewife
because basically what she did was she
said she changed
got the kids that she wanted from
russell and then when she got what she
wanted she's doing this [ __ ] again
do you guys think that's acceptable
behavior from a wife
i mean
she's a she's a dancer okay but
it depends on how much she said she's
changed because i don't know how much
she said she's
she waited till she was married with
russell oh [ __ ] well before she started
working was she a mother no no to have
sex what yeah it hurt you didn't know
that well
oh okay i'm sorry i left a piece of the
story absolutely yeah so so basically
after she dated the bad boy she said she
changed she was a new person
and she decided yeah found god and women
tend to find god around like 27 to like
30s early 30s because because it's in
like times running out so they need to
base it's a mating strategy so they need
to basically say i'm more pure than i
actually am
and like i'm a higher value woman than i
actually am basically but she was a
virgin no no no no no no
no no no no no no that's the point so
she she slept with all the rappers and
then made the next guy yeah okay
she says she would change didn't have
sex with anybody and then once she got
rustled then that's when she went back
in yeah so they dated for a year didn't
have sex they got married and so she
this is he's thinking this is a godly
one it's the same thing with megan good
i don't
yeah um but
but basically
now
she got they get they got the kids
they're a little bit older
and now this behavior is coming back 10
years later basically
so she was already having the kids at
that time of the video
no this is now so she has three kids now
yes
dated now basically yes
and the the and the argument is you
can't marry a hoe because she will
always return to the streets
i hear that um in terms of like the
twerking
i think i'm giving her a lot of leeway
because she's a dancer but if she
actually was like became born again and
she was just
full-on christian wasn't doing anything
like that then yeah but in terms of her
career
you don't think you can she's a
performer
you can't you can't perform without
twerking
on a car
yeah
i think it's similar to how you were
saying that um
um
the wherever that young guy's name is
and how he was trapped by brittany
renner yeah um so it's like ej
washington yeah so like i don't know
about i think yeah i think part of kim
k's brand is giving glogglog so what
should she return to gibbon blog because
that's how she got famous oh
it's not great that's a great analogy
it's it's it's it's an analogy
it's a great one
yeah i don't i don't i don't think
that's the comment i don't think i don't
think it's appropriate i don't think
it's appropriate behavior
i don't think it's appropriate behavior
but
i don't know i'm kind of excusing it i
wouldn't
um
she's autistic
but she like she has yeah i'm not
disregarding that she's a dancer i
i grew up listening to sierra group
seeing her love her music videos but
there's a way like you are portraying
yourself in this way you're portraying
yourself at this as this
wife the essential wife with the family
and everything and then
what there's there's no context of
choreography there's no context of a
song being released there's no context
of that to be able to do that it's just
hey i got these dancers we're going to
go twerk on a car at a gas station i
think it's not a song
i think it's because i never saw her as
whatever she rebranded herself as
i think that oh sierra yeah i think that
might be why no because that's not good
that's the thing she's claiming to be
brand new she's just like
no sex before marriage i'm a christian
now
then now you're doing madness yeah
that's yeah i guess she was doing that
if she posted a video and she was
twerking on russell i'd be like oh hey
girl that's your man like go ahead do
that but now it's out of the context of
but when it's just her it's not okay
it it sends like a mixed signal because
if it's just imagine if it if you and
your girls got a car went to the petrol
station it was like we're going to twerk
real quick and then your daughter
friends sitting around squirrel
scrolling and sawing yeah and they're
like is this your mom it's like yeah
it's my mom why is she twerking at a
petrol station on a car it's just
it's
difficult because now she's in a setting
to where that not only affects it's not
her anymore it's not her image it
affects her kids and affects russell's
image now that she is doing that and
exposing herself
married right yes and do you think that
she wouldn't have discussed it with him
before do you think she just knows this
and maybe she doesn't feel like she did
this and he had no maybe she doesn't
feel like
i think russell's a samp
and i think i think a lot of guys have
been so conditioned
that they don't even know what they want
see do you think it should be a man a
woman expresses her sexuality only in
relation to her man and if it's
i i think her on her own even though he
is as you said a one percent man
it is not okay unless he's there
i i what do you mean by expressing her
sexuality perhaps she likes working
perhaps it makes her feel good perhaps
it's something that when she sees
herself she's like
she can
i think i think
it's provocative it's something that's
gonna
generate her more income it's going to
get people talking about so
so if i have kids and i want to start an
only fans because it generates more
income do you think that's a good
representation of my kids and my husband
i was on a henry recently um
and uh one of the girls i just met her
on the hand too i've never met her
before she was actually a virgin when
she got married
uh and she said her boss
she had i think it's a bell i don't know
do you have any fans anyone what's that
a hit like a a bachelorette okay okay
uh so yeah we're on a bachelorette and
she said she heard her boss
a bell went off on his phone she was
like i've heard that sound before
where's that from
she'd heard it on tik tok it's from only
fans turns out him and his wife have a
bdsm only fans they're married with kids
do you think that's an optimal
environment for kids to grow up in with
um basically anyone can pay ten dollars
and see their parents having sex because
if you come if you if you went to my
school your mum's breast is going around
all demanding facts
you know your mom's best maybe not
optimal but reality now so what do you
think
what do you what effect do you think
that will have do you think it's just
going to become the norm do you think
i hope i think i hope not all my mates
bashing over my mom's breasts like no
what if they did it anyway without a
picture
what would they'll be they just saw it
but that's not the same okay it's there
for advertisement
because at the end of the day it's it's
selfish because you're putting you above
your kid you're putting like wanting
quick cash because that's another way
women are bailed out right if a man
doesn't have a job he's just homeless
if a woman doesn't want to work she can
go on only fans and make six figures
yeah and so it's it's it's
you can't really feel bad for those
girls either and say oh you're forced to
be sexualized because i don't feel bad
yeah no it's good good
be good but a lot of a lot of those
girls will say that and then come in
after mia khalifa right
and then come back and what's the other